ja das geht ich stehe auf einer matratze
die auf dem boden liegt und ich werde
jetzt fragen beantworten wo ab erst mal
sorry für die beleuchtung und so gestern
hatte mein vater geburtstag und ich bin
jetzt noch bei ihm
und da habe ich natürlich nicht mal
nochmals equipment hier ist nur schnell
die kamera angepackt leonie fragt hast
du irgendwelche reiseziele für dieses
jahr beziehungsweise dein leben sowie
standard frage welche ich nur schon
wieder beantwortet weil ich ein paar
gute ideen habe eigentlich reiseziel bei
dem beide idee eigentlich nicht direkt
und zwei möchte ich gern mit meiner
freundin motrip machen
das wird glaube ich richtig cool also so
verwegen dass man nicht genau weiß wo
man morgen früh dann ist so mäßig so
cool
das wäre glaube ich spannend und das
habe ich auf jeden fall von texten
was würdest du jetzt machen wenn du
draußen wärs wahrscheinlich nass werden
weil es regnet gerade ein bisschen und
ich will früher aber komische frage lido
youtube fragt wirst du irgendwann aktive
auf instagram falls ich habe schon
gesagt ich würde bestimmt werden stand
irgendwann aktive auf instagram nur
irgendwie weil sie nicht so großartig
was postenlauf in scrum und irgendwie
dieses ständige stars machen es mir ein
bisschen geht ein bisschen auf die
nerven
und deshalb weiß ich nicht genau was ich
da also posten soll aber ich werde
bestimmt bald wieder mehr wähler posten
weil weniger wähler als erste posten
geht wahrscheinlich gar nicht bei wem
hast du zuletzt danke gesagt und wieso
bei einem kaffee getrunken und der
canadian kaffee bestellen euch gesagt
danke an fragt könntest du dir
vorstellen konkreter zu heiraten
er steckt der fisch ist geschockt ja das
wird meine freunde warum immer so
kreativ fest
warum immer so kreative hashtags hashtag
der fisches geschöpft warum immer so
kreative hashtags hashtag der fisch
geschockt war der fisch gestoppt ist
umfrage wer ist dein lieblings oldschool
rapper dmx eminem oder so ich mag gerne
bigair ansonsten also eminem ist ja
nicht wirklich oldschool bzw
doch der war schon relativ früh mit
dabei hat bigelows also bild mag ich
gerne und nase des königreichs man hat
die sind richtig cool also diesen
vollkommen andere rated vor allem
hierzulande für mich weil es ist einfach
mega gut wie spät ist es bei dir gerade
922 wenig dass gerade aufnehmen warum
haben fischschuppen grafische geschockt
sind kannst du hier folgen ein duell
zeitmaschine hätte ist in welches
jahrhundert würdest du reisen
also ich bin mir aber ziemlich
technologie begeistert deshalb würde ich
vielleicht in zukunft reisen also bei
einer zeitmaschine nämlich jetzt einfach
mal an dass man auch in zukunft reisen
kann das wäre ziemlich blöde
zeitmaschinen ansonsten was wenn ich
noch spannend ich fänd ansonsten
spannend mal sich die zeit anzuschauen
wo einfach die zivilisation noch nicht
so krank ausgeprägt war also wohl noch
nicht überall straßen mussten auch
flecken da wo einfach kein mensch zuvor
war und das fände ich glaube ich echt
cool
das würde ich mir auch anschauen aber
ansonsten eher technologie also
eigentlich voll am teetisch hast du
gerade im moment hunger es gibt aber
mein papa und seine frau wochen gerade
würdest du so was mit den heftigen maut
strikt noch mal machen wollen aber dann
zum beispiel in amerika oder so ja auf
jeden fall recht cool
er kann zwar nicht so
super gut bei den zuschauern an aber bei
mir ist halt auch das real life segment
nicht so ausgeprägt sag ich mal wie
anderes und deshalb kann ich mir das zu
erklären aber ich hätte auf jeden fall
recht bock nochmal so etwas zu machen
leonie würdest du ein buch lesen mit
einer ganzen lebensgeschichte würde ich
nicht auf keinen fall
das war es dann auch für heutigen video
ich hoffe man hört mich noch obwohl ich
gerade gut geklappt habe jetzt hat sich
weg